peut-être quelques mots sur déjà mon
engagement pourquoi j'ai souhaité
participer à ce comité de gouvernance
comme coprésident j'ajouterai dans la
très très extinct présentation très
développée que vous avez fait que je
suis aussi membre du haut conseil pour
le climat que vous avez je crois
auditionné récemment et c'est aussi dans
cet aller retour entre les analyses de
ce haut conseil pour lequel mois
l'installation du lequel j'ai beaucoup
oeuvré pendant depuis plusieurs années
et je me réjouis sonné aussi un organe
scientifiques qui permettent un peu de
réfléchir et de prendre un peu de
distance par rapport aux un peu au court
disons quotidien des choses alors je ne
vous apprendrai rien en disant que cette
cette question la situation que
climatique est évidemment très
préoccupante pour tout le monde
on a eu une année de 2020 la plus chaude
enregistrée par météo-france enfin pas
seulement par météo france
tous les organismes et théologiques et
la motivation pour moi de m'associer à
cet exercice nouveau c'est vraiment
peut-être la plus fondamentale c'est le
répondre à cette urgence signifie un
changement très profond des sociétés où
nous vivons que aléas émissions nettes 0
en 2050
ce à quoi d'ailleurs la france s'est
engagée aux côtés d'autres pays
européens mais aujourd'hui maintenant de
plus en plus de pays signifie quand on
regarde d'ailleurs ce qu'on est capable
de faire en jeu d'hier en en faisant un
peu mieux que le quotidien il ya un
décalage considérable entre cela ce
qu'on devrait faire et on le mesure dans
les rapports les deux rapports que le
haut conseil a publié pour la france on
est très en dessous
déjà de ce que la france était donné
comme objectif de réduction annuelle
notre objectif devrait être au moins
devraient être dans le passé d'avoir été
de réduction des émissions de 1.5 % par
an en fait il faut à falloir qu'on
accélère déjà par rapport à cette norme
que nous n'arrivons pas à remplir
puisque nous sommes encore une fois très
en dessous les émissions françaises ont
baissé de 0.9 % par rapport à 2010 82 en
2019 et très largement parce que 2019 a
été une année assez chaude et que les
besoins de chauffage ont été limités
donc on est dans un décalage très grand
entre les objectifs qui sont pris au
plan politique auquel évidemment se
massent aussi complètement et la réalité
de la politique et des changements sur
le cas alors on a quand même des choses
qui sont positives et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut accompagner ce changement
évidemment l'accord de paris que j'ai eu
le privilège de négocier génère marche
enfin il génère un effet domino positif
en tout cas peut pas dire évidemment
aujourd'hui on n'en est pas au résultat
sur l'économie réelle
mais l'union européenne a provoqué
finalement un mouvement important dans
la chine aujourd'hui rejoints par les
états unis et beaucoup de pays émergents
se fixe aujourd'hui un objectif qui
paraissait en 2015 complètement de
porter qui sont de baisser les émissions
à 0 net c'est-à-dire en enlevant les
puits de carbone en 2050 ou peu de temps
après donc on doit revoir tous nos
objectifs on doit renforcer nos
stratégies notamment la stratégie
nationale bas carbone française
on est là la stratégie nationale bas
carbone française qui franchement ils
vont permettre à être très diplomate là
n'est pas du tout la feuille de route de
tous les ministères du gouvernement
français et c'est en une référence qui
au fond des influences pas aujourd'hui
pour l'instant les politiques d'une
façon générale et c'est sans doute
évidemment l'objectif de ce nouveau
projet de loi donc tout ça veut dire que
s'il n'y a pas d'engagement de la
société importants et aujourd'hui je
préside la fondation européenne pour le
climat qui essaie de soutenir les
actions des citoyens pas seulement des
citoyens mais aussi des entreprises et
de tous ceux qui veulent aller plus vite
le seul constat qu'on peut faire c'est
qu'il ya un consensus dans la société
sans doute l'un pour percevoir le risque
climatique les études que nous avons
financé nom de notre destin commun
montre qu'il ya un facteur d'unité dans
la société française sur la perception
de ce risque et la nécessité d'y lutter
non c'est pas un facteur de division
comme ça a pu l'être tout ça l'est
encore aux états unis par exemple mais
qu'en même temps les changements sont si
profonds que une décision seulement par
le haut nous n'a pas fonctionné parce
que c'est beaucoup de choses c'est des
comportements individuels c'est des
choix collectifs c'est aussi des
programmes évidemment gouvernementaux et
donc la conscientisation rapide
les mouvements de jeunesse les
évidemment les inquiétudes par rapport à
l'agriculture l'alimentation aux
transports on voit qu'il faut pas
reporter les choix mais quand même temps
ses choix ils doivent être partagés
d'où l'intérêt de l'exercice de la
convention citoyenne puisque il ya la
fois
la compréhension des enjeux et des
problèmes et en même temps la difficulté
et l'impossibilité de les conduire dans
un cadre existence rappelons-nous
évidemment la crise des gilet jaune et
la réaction très vive en tout cas de
groupes de population à 7 à cette
augmentation de la taxe carbone on sait
aussi il l'étude de carbone 4 l'a montré
qu' on peut bien sûr on peut recommander
aux uns et aux autres d'être vertueux
mais le citoyen français le plus
vertueux même s'il faisait tout comme un
héros ne jamais pu prendre l'avion
presque jamais sa voiture ne ferait que
entamé bien peu les émissions françaises
1 25% au fond de ses 11 tonnes
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre par
an qui sont la totalité des émissions
quand on compte les importations est
encore une fois bien sûr les émissions
françaises d'origine française fait sur
le sol français
elles sont moins élevés en dessous de 6
tonnes d'équivalent co2 par an mais nous
en portons le reste est à en 2050 9 0c
net zéro pour tout le monde c'est pas
net 0 pour la france et puis les autres
vrai autrement
donc il ya cette espèce de budget
carbone qui nous contraint et une grande
difficulté politique à celui de ceux
couverts non seulement des précédents
aussi à répondre à l'enjeu est donc il
faut il faut un grand changement et il
me semble que le le fait de recourir à
la consultation citoyenne ce qui est
certainement un exercice dans son
ampleur originales en français
il faut évidemment salué le
l'intention du gouvernement du président
de la république de lancer cet exercice
mais il n'est pas nouveau d'autres pays
l'ont fait on pense évidemment à
l'exemple célèbre delà de l'irlande sur
des questions sociales très très
difficile
l'hypothèse faisant que si les citoyens
sont consultés directement dans un
processus où il y à un processus non pas
de sondages mais de réflexion et
d'élaboration des politiques
eh bien on a une chance de savoir au
fond où en est la société française et
du coup l'élaboration de ces politiques
d'être plus raccord plus en phase avec
ce que pense la société puisqu'au fond
et ça m'a toujours frappé comme bon je
m'occupe du climat depuis beaucoup trop
longtemps parce que c'est ça devrait
déjà être réglés mais je te veux frapper
de ce qui vient tout de suite dans la
bouche de beaucoup de responsables
politiques alors on a vraiment de tout
beaucoup d'appartenance de dire les
citoyens ne sont pas prêts et au fond le
mieux c'est de leur demander ce qu'ils
sont prêts à faire et surtout qu'est-ce
qui souhaite que le collectif face
puisque encore une fois individuellement
peuvent pas faire tellement de choses
d'entre elles peuvent faire des choses
mais ils peuvent surtout construire le
consensus pour que la société change
donc je vais peut-être raccourcir mon
propos introductif essayer de répondre à
vos questions
donc je pense qu'effectivement cet
excellent elles sont nombreuses et pour
ça il faut jouer discipline vos
questions sur d'abord le au fond la
qualité démocratique de l'exercice le je
crois qu'il y ait on est discuté en tout
cas malheureusement pas avec vous mais
dans le processus lui-même avec la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale
on peut comprendre l'émotion des élus
mais cette cct convention citoyenne non
absolument pas évidemment ça me paraît
même tomber sous le sens vocation à
remplacer l'exercice démocratique
représentatif sinon je crois qu on
marcherait sur la tête
en revanche il ya vraiment un
une relation importante entre citoyens
et élus je dirais aussi importante
d'ailleurs contre citoyens et cela
qu'ils ont délégué leur pouvoir de
décision qui me paraît être quelque
chose qui permet peut-être
progressivement de restituer
reconstruire la confiance des citoyens
dans les institutions de la république
je vous apprendrai rien sur l'état de
défiance s'est pas seulement en france
c'est donc vraiment beaucoup de pays
démocratiques et c'est un moyen il y en
a beaucoup d'autres
il faut certainement pas sacraliser
celui là mais de d'instaurer un dialogue
à condition que et cette convention
citoyenne a permis d'aller très loin
puisque n'a pas seulement demander
l'opinion ces citoyens dans un cadre
effectivement réflexif mais de proposer
des solutions donc des solutions qui
sont des solutions assez aboutis très
aboutie dans certains cas donc je dirais
que peut-être c'est maintenant à la
représentation nationale dans toute sa
diversité de se dire oh vous qu'est ce
qu'on peut imaginer comme nouveau
processus nouvelles opportunités pour
que ce dialogue non pas entre deux
mandats entre deux des débutants demanda
au moment de se présenter devant les
électeurs mais aussi devant des citoyens
qui sont aussi en charge deux de ces
changements au même titre que les élus
et donc on n'a pas de on n'a pas
aujourd'hui de mécanismes on hamm est
sans doute vous en plus qui est rentré
dans les territoires vous voyez déjà
beaucoup moins de l'exercice de cette
nature ou proches se réveillait donc est
ce qu'il nous faut des règles
il nous faut juste d'abord je dirais
pour l'instant beaucoup de
d'expérimentation et de tirer les leçons
de ces expérimentations
ce qui me paraît très important en
revanche et à garder c'est que une fois
l'exercice fini il faut qu'ils aient un
grand respect pour le travail de ses
citoyens et ne pas les traiter
je dirai à la légère c'est tout les gens
ont travaillé je sais qu'elle 2
convention citoyenne qui se sont
déroulées dans les territoires il ya pas
très longtemps notamment dans la région
occitanie considérer la valeur de ce
travail me paraît être là encore une
fois la condition de la continuer on a
continué de reconstruction de la
confiance
vous m'avez demandé aussi donc sur la
méthode il ya certainement des choses à
améliorer
je pense qu'il faut faire un bilan
maintenant plus plus spécifique mais je
crois qu'en tout cas en approuver deux
choses que les citoyens français sont
attentifs à la chose publique et ne sont
pas désengagé et passifs ce ne sont pas
des enfants
ils ont des idées assez claires et ils
peuvent responsable ils sont prêts à
faire des choix difficiles à condition
qu'ils soient mûri collectivement est ce
que est ce que le projet de loi mais
jean pierre cabrol développera cela
davantage s'il le veut bien puisque
c'est à lui de juger et non pas à moi
mais bien sûr on est loin quand même en
très grande partie parce que toutes les
mesures de la convention et vous avez
raison monsieur le président il ya
beaucoup plus que 140 949 c'était une
technique de vote pour que l'on puisse
voter dans des délais normaux mais bien
sûr il y en a beaucoup d'autres et même
celle là on sait qu'on n'arrivait pas au
moins 40% avec celle là un le thé
d'ailleurs c'est toujours difficile à
chiffrer
il ya des questions évidemment sur
l'étude d'impact qui a été fait très
rapidement et présenter pour le projet
de loi par le gouvernement
donc de toute façon on est en est sans
doute pas
à la barre que nous étions en train de
chercher mais tous les retards au fond
quand on regarde un peu le projet de loi
c'est au fond reprendre des idées ou une
bonne partie d'entre elles pas tout
effectivement vous avez pointé le
numérique on peut pointer au monde
d'autres secteurs qui sont absents mais
pour le reste c'est beaucoup de en prend
du temps on repousse dans le temps les
obligations
on repousse dans autant les objectifs et
si j'avais une coloration a donné
généralement de ce projet de loi c'est
plutôt ça il ya des secteurs qu'on a
effectivement oublié les instruments
fiscaux sont mal acceptée manifestement
pas le gouvernement je pense à cette
question de la tva différencier sur un
certain nombre de produits
mais pour le reste
on reprend un peu la philosophie mais on
décale dans le temps et c'est peut-être
ça qui me préoccupe parce qu'on n'a pas
le temps je regarde la question
simplement compliqué hein de
l'électrification du transport en france
on voit que nos collègues britanniques
ont décidé que c'était 2030 la fin de la
vente des véhicules électriques
je pense que ce mouvement va s'étendre
très très rapidement d'autres pays je
pense à l'allemagne en particulier
et puis que sinon être envahis de
véhicules chinois extrêmement rapidement
alors est ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est raisonnable de
repousser encore et ça c'est un exemple
parmi d'autres la rénovation des
bâtiments si on n'y va pas beaucoup avec
un processus d'industrialisation de la
rénovation donc une organisation de la
filière et ça prend du temps
si on le fait pas maintenant avec cette
question d'obligation non pas à
repousser à très loin mais ça n'a pas
l'effet d'entraînement et d'organisation
que tous les ministres qui se sont
occupés de ce secteur du bâtiment
connaissent un une résistance c'est
normal mais il ya un moment où justement
il faut pouvoir bâtir dessus
est-ce qu'elle co construction je dirais
là dessus au fond le la qualité de ce
processus
en tout cas dans notre esprit avec
thierry pech qui est le comité de
gouvernance qui nous avons animé
c'était de dire les citoyens font la
proposition ils sont écoutés
alors l'interprétation du sans filtre a
été assez extensif c'est vrai le dire
parce qu'ils aient beaucoup de jokers
quand même mais c'est après au
gouvernement et surtout ensuite à la
représentation nationale de prendre ses
responsabilités donc le fait qu'ils
payent de co-construction moi ne me
choque pas
mais bon peut-être que je me trompe
peut-être qu'il ya une espèce de phase
ii de ophain il ya la phase 1 de la
convention si fine ces propositions la
phase 2 de l'élaboration des projets de
lois des règlements de la loi de
finances et puis peut-être qu'il
faudrait avoir une un moment de retour
non pas seulement du jugement là c'est
ensuite ça va être le jugement des
citoyens sur le projet de loi mais
quelque chose qui serait plus plus
interactif et ça il faut peut-être créer
quelque chose je ne je ne venais pas je
n'ai pas participé évidemment aux
bourdes de travail et donc je ne sais
pas comment jean pierre cameron le dira
mieux que moi attaché pas vraiment
d'avis sur la question
je pense qu'effectivement ce qui me
paraît peut-être le plus préoccupant
c'est le monde dans le mandat des
citoyens la question de justice sociale
était posée par la lettre de mission du
premier ministre
les citoyens ont pris très au sérieux
j'ai l'impression que ça ne disparut
plutôt de les réflexions on sait il y
avait beaucoup de propositions très
intéressantes alors je vois qu'un acte
qui reviennent après la réunion entre le
président de la république et les
citoyens sur les chèques alimentaires
mais je pense que ça très sérieusement
cette question de la justice sociale
précarité des ménages il a tout de même
14 % des ménages français qui sont
concernés par la précarité énergétique
c'est cinquante mille et c'est beaucoup
mais ses pattes en france mais c'est
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui
dont le budget est très largement
impacté par la facture énergétique que
ça soit transport chauffage etc et
aujourd'hui tout ce qui est la
technologie de l'information qui sans de
façon très son mieux sur noye si on peut
dire consomme ce budget 2 et par
ailleurs on a une égalité territoriale
majeur vis-à-vis du risque du changement
climatique
elle est forte la france est un des pays
qui sera les plus impactés bon j'ai pas
et donc du point de vue de l'ambition je
pense que d'une façon générale et là je
reprendrai ce que disent mes collègues
du conseil
on n'y pas encore en certainement pas en
plus à un moment de renforcement de
l'objectif européen de pour 2030 le même
que le même la même date que notre -40%
il va falloir qu'on revoie certainement
nos objectifs je suis d'accord avec vous
que l'absence du numérique est un vrai
souci
les émissions liées à la technologie de
l'information
lorsqu'on est passé de la 3g à la 4g ont
bondi il n'y a pas vraiment de raison
que ce soit différent
en tout cas c'est pas prouvé que ce soit
différent entre passé de la 4g à la 5g
par exemple voilà un côté je crois que
il faut sans doute un moment de
réflexion
ce serait je trouve extraordinairement
utile que vous avec la vous comme
représentant vous vous y réfléchissez à
quels seraient les mécanismes pour créer
cette relation s'il y en avait une et
sous quelle forme je dirais entre ces
deux moments très importants que son
vote
qu'est ce que c'est les formes de
consultation est ce que ça doit être
essentiellement dans le cadre
territorial
quelle est la valeur justement mais et
je me réjouis de voir votre vigilance
ans sur le projet de loi parce que je
crois que on doit reconnaître l'effort
considérable et citoyen est pensée comme
les sondages nous disent que les
citoyens sont derrière une très très
grande majorité des mesures qui sont
proposés par la convention citoyenne
merci j'ai été longue et j'ai ensuite
comment que je regarde les les questions
auxquelles je n'ai pas la banque
merci je viens d'achever des appareils
amitié cameron bonjour bonjour mesdames
bonjour monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs merci déjà nous recevoir nous
porter cette attention et j'ai la lourde
tâche de de parler au nom des 150
donc je fais je vais commencer si vous
le voulez bien par me présenter donc je
m'appelle jean pierre cabrol j'ai 58 ans
bientôt je vis en haute savoie au pays
du mont blanc face au mont blanc
d'ailleurs dans une vallée qui s'appelle
la vallée de l'arve l'une des ballets
les plus polluées de france en
l'occurrence je suis chef d'antenne
confirmée par notre collègue s'est
grippée loi qui est relax enchanté voilà
il faut préciser les choses assez
rapidement donc je suis chef
d'entreprise et mon métier ce sont les
matières plastiques le recyclage voilà
ce fait 30 ans que j'exerce ce métier et
c'est pas pour autant que j'avais une
notion très précise du dérèglement
climatique et de et de l'impérieuse
nécessité de travailler à l'amélioration
de climat je vais je vais vous parler
assez rapidement de l'état d'esprit dans
lequel nous sommes arrivés de ce que
nous avons appris et puis de ce qui nous
est apparu comme important dans la
défense de nos mesures
nous sommes pour la majorité tous
arrivés non écolo et nous en sommes
repartis de la même façon de cette
convention
la notion que vous avez que nous avions
et comme je vous l'expliquais de du
dérèglement climatique et de la
nécessité de bien faire s'arrêter un peu
bout de notre jardin c'est à dire que
l'information qui circule en france sur
la nécessité de recyclage vous de bien
faire pour notre environnement est
relativement limitée au cours de du
premier week-end de nos cette session
nous avons appris et reçu une multitude
d'informations sur le dérèglement
climatique
les causes et les effets et je dois vous
dire que pour la majorité d'entre nous
la question était de savoir s'il fallait
poursuivre ou rentrer chez nous en
courant et attendre que les choses se
passaient et voire ignoré un petit peu
ce que nous avions appris les choses
sont les suivantes si rien n'est fait en
2050 la température moyenne augmentera
entre 3 et 5 degrés d'accord les accords
de paris vous le savez c'est de limiter
à 1,5 degré l'augmentation des
températures
si rien n'est fait la fin de ce siècle
c'est presque la moitié de la surface
terrestre qui ne sera plus habitable
pour des dérèglements climatiques
évident et pour respecter des accords de
paris qui sont aujourd'hui obsolètes en
termes de de réduction de gaz à effet de
serre puisque l'europe a décidé de
passer à moins 55%
il faut pouvoir chaque année à partir
d'aujourd'hui et réduire de 7 5% nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre voilà
ce sur quoi nous avons travaillé la
réussite de cette convention c'est que
le l'objectif qui nous a été fixé était
on ne peut plus clair impossible d'en
dévier c'est de réduire de 40% à 2030
dans l'espagne de justice sociale
l'organisation que nous avons vécu était
assez simple c'est l identifier les
principaux groupes pollueurs et en
l'occurrence ce sont le premier le
transport 30% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre c'est pas simplement la
voiture c'est aussi le maritime c'est
l'aérien le deuxième c'est l'agriculture
ses 27% et le troisième poste important
c'est l'habitat 25% des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre
la représentativité de cette convention
c'est alors vous le savez c'est un
tirage au sort j'ai un petit peu de vécu
excusez moi je m'étouffe un peu avec mon
masque mais ça va passer
c'est le sujet et de pouvoir vous
expliquer clairement simplement et des
passionnés un peu le débat puisque ça
fait quand même presque un an qu'on est
dessus et donc c'est vrai c'est on est
on peut pas être impliqué enfin autant
de temps sans être un peu passionné sur
le sujet
la représentativité des 150 merci merci
les 150 je vous disais c'est
effectivement une véritable
représentativité de la population
française gg que 58 ans je suis un jeune
garçon mais mais j'ai quand même passé
pas mal de gens dans ma vie est
effectivement je peux vous assurer que
j'ai vu les mêmes personnes au sein de
la convention c'est à dire des gens qui
avaient une intelligence assez
extraordinaire des gens avec des égos
démesurés des gens très simples des gens
qui n'avaient pas d'idée de tout âge de
tout bord politique de toute culture
générale et de tout milieu social le
formidable de cette convention c'est
d'avoir eu la capacité de nous écouter
tous de nous entendre et de pouvoir
travailler ensemble nous avons travaillé
par groupes
par rapport au groupe identifié comme
étant des groupes pollueurs ou émetteur
de gaz à effet de serre et nous avons
tous ensemble travailler sur les mesures
qui nous paraissaient les plus
essentiels en termes d'efficacité sur la
réalité
le gain des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre de notre rapport nous n'avons pas
mesuré par manque de temps et puis
également parce que le travail qu'il
était nécessaire de faire pour le
mesurer et mais est immense est
important donc il existe au sein de la
convention
un groupe d'appui qui se charge
aujourd'hui d'essayer de quantifier les
réductions proposées par nos mesures et
le lien que je pourrais faire par
rapport au projet de loi c'est
qu'effectivement il nous a été dit que
et c'est vrai je pense que le constat
est une réalité même si on n'a pas une
unité précise une mesure précise de nos
mesures que nous n'atteignons pas les
-40%
mais c'est pas pour autant que le projet
ou que les futurs projets de loi doivent
faire moins bien au contraire ils
doivent faire plus je rappelle qu'il
faut réduire à partir d'aujourd'hui et
chaque année de 7,5 pour cent des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
en application si on dessine est
aujourd'hui un projet de loi qui
permettrait d'appliquer certaines
mesures à partir de 2028 comme j'ai pu
le lire on sera pas dans les clous donc
le sujet n'est pas de dire en 2030
ça y est l'ensemble des mesures
permettent de réduire de 40% pas le ciel
sera effective en 2030 c'est une
ce n'est pas une réalité il nous faudra
dix ans supplémentaires
l'effort qu'il est nécessaire de faire
aujourd'hui sera d'autant plus difficile
si on ne le fait pas maintenant
demain c'est pas moins 40 c bon 55 et
après demain ce sera peut-être moins 65
ans au moins 70%
donc au delà de tout aspect politique
des choses que je peux prendre en
considération et nous ne sommes pas
politique ne sommes pas des
professionnels de la politique et du et
du climat mais nous avons une réflexion
simple et claire sur la nécessité
impérieuse de travailler à des mesures
nécessaires pour la réduction des gaz à
effet de serre
non j'ai pas terminée s'cusez moi je
veux juste revenir sur deux points
j'ai noté dans ce qui a été dit parlant
ce qu'ils sont
est ce que le le climat et les efforts
qui sont nécessaires sont sont un
facteur de division sanaa société je ne
crois pas on l'a vu comme je voulais ni
on est une représentativité de la france
et on était tous d'accord sur la
nécessité impérieuse de travail et je
crois qu'il le plus le l'essentiel ou le
manquements importants au sein de nos
sociétés c'est l'information
je voulais dit nous sommes arrivés de
bonne information et nous avons pris une
claque monumentale au premier week-end
avec toutes les informations qui
auraient pu recevoir sur les causes et
des effets je crois qu'aujourd'hui et
pour avoir discuté avec mes voisins mes
amis les gens que je peux retrouver dans
mon village
les gens sont pas informés de ce qui se
passe les gens ont conscience qu'il est
nécessaire a effectivement le climat se
réchauffe peut-être un peu plus au pays
du mont blanc parce qu'on voit un peu le
mont blanc l'été qui commence à fondre
un peu plus qu'habituellement mais ça
s'arrête là ça nous change pas la vie
j'ai souvent tendance à assimiler le
fait que le dérèglement climatique c'est
un petit peu comme le tabagisme c'est à
tous les matins vous pouvez continuer
bien et puis un jour le diagnostic va
tomber et là c'est un peu tard
malheureusement donc je crois qu'il est
nécessaire de se mettre un peu en marche
et par contre immédiatement sur la
nécessité de même si ça nous coûte
effectivement de l'argent même si
effectivement c'est un changement de vie
qui a des efforts à ces importants à
faire mais il faut le faire parce que
demain ce sera pire
ça sera plus il faudra faire plus ça
sera plus douloureux ça sera plus
difficile à mettre en oeuvre
voilà c'est ce que je voulais vous ou
bien sûr merci
merci pour ce merci pour ce témoignage
effectivement qui était un témoignage
intéressant d'un industriel qui en plus
travail au recyclage du plastique c'est
intéressant je pense que vous avez je
crois que vous avez eu une phrase qui
est forte c'est celle que il faut
communiquer parce que c'est vrai qu'on
nous donne toujours l'impression de
d'essayer de casser quelque chose qui
qui pour ce qu'on casse marche mais je
crois qu'il faut effectivement donné
explique revenir sur ses explications
pour essayer de convaincre de faire
comprendre et la comparaison avec le
avec le tabac est une quelque chose
d'intéressant
merci pour ce témoignage je vais donner
la parole à evelyne perron
oui merci président madame taux bien à
j'ai une question pour vous apporter à
l'ensemble de l'effort que doit faire la
france pour parvenir à la neutralité
carbone en 2050
quelle est la part des 149 propositions
peut-on évaluer en pourcentage l'impact
de toutes ces propositions en économie
de co2 par rapport à la totalité de
l'effort à fournir et en miroir quel
impact pour l'activité économique
merci de prendre trois questions de
suite et puis après vous réponds vous
répondre et on va on paie question ronan
dantec
oui merci monsieur le président vous
avez dit en introduction
puis on en a beaucoup parlé à travers
des différentes interventions que
actuellement la loi c'était à peu près
la moitié du chemin par rapport à
l'objectif
mais l'objectif au moment de la
convention citoyenne était à -40 % en
2030 et depuis l'union européenne a fixé
un objectif à -55 pour ça en 2030 ce qui
veut dire qu'en fait la loi telle
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
tiens plutôt un tiers de l'objectif donc
évidemment on n'est pas du tout sur une
trajectoire compatible avec l'accord de
paris c'est extrêmement clair donc du
coup
deux questions la première là aussi ça a
été un petit peu dit par parleront du
bien à tout à l'heure
et vous venez de le dire concernant les
actuels travaux de la convention
citoyenne je pense qu'une des
difficultés y compris pour pour le
parlement et pour les décideurs en
général c'est qu'on est assez peu
adossés à des scénarios quantitatif
crédible y compris à des scénarios
alternatifs qui permet aux politiques de
prendre des décisions mais en étant
adossée à l'objectif et l'objectif c'est
moins de 55 % en 2030
donc je voulais poser la question
laurence tubiana compris en tant que
président de l'as de la fondation
européenne sur le climat de savoir où on
en est finalement de ce travail sur les
scénarios quantitatif qui moi me semble
quand même une vraie faiblesse
aujourd'hui du débat y compris pour
éclairer la représentation nationale est
derrière la deuxième question alors on
en a un peu parlé finalement à travers
l'exemple des véhicules électriques
c'est que je pense qu'il ya un grand
absent dans le débat stratégique
aujourd'hui qui pourtant absolument
incontournable qui est l'europe
quand on parle par exemple des des
émissions à porter c'est clair que c'est
pas le cadre national qui est le cadre
central le cadre central c'est le cadre
européen c'est les grands accords
internationaux c'est peut-être demain
mécanisme aux frontières sur la tonne
co2 et que là quand on regarde les
stratégies des pays européens ce que ce
que se fait aussi avec ma propre
association qu'on regarde par exemple la
mobilité la stratégie de la suède est
inverse de celle de la norvège encore
très très différente de celle de
l'allemagne ou au delà notre écrit
nalement il n'y a pas de stratégie
commune industrielle ou politiques des
différents pays européens et que ce
morcellement ne permet pas en fait
d'atteindre l'objectif donc ma question
l'eurostudio nice et 2
voir où on en est finalement du
rapprochement des politiques publiques
en europe et aussi de la volonté de
l'union européenne d'aller dans ce sens
là merci maintenant je salue nos
collègues qui nous suivent en visio et
je donne la parole à nicole bonnefoy
j'espère que ça va mieux nicole oui
merci président bonjour madame me yann à
mes chers collègues
en ce qui me concerne je suis co
rapporteur avec mon collègue rémy
pointereau d'une mission d'information
sur le transport des marchandises face
aux impératifs environnementaux
la convention citoyenne a formulé un
certain nombre de propositions sur le
sujet mais je souhaitais avoir votre
sentiment général sur la question du
transport des marchandises à destination
des particuliers
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que le
transport où les transports étaient en
termes d'émissions de gaz à effet de
serre le plus important donc ne pensez
vous pas qu'en plus des dispositifs
relatifs au verdissement de véhicules
c'est-à-dire uniquement les réponses
techniques ou technologiques et des
différents leviers fiscaux
nous devons nous devons questionner le
modèle existant et interroger nos modes
de consommation
il me semble par exemple que le
développement du juste à temps
ce système économique juste à temps et
particulièrement néfastes sur le plan
environnemental
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que les
citoyens sont prêts à s'engager était
prêt à faire des choix difficiles à
condition qu'ils soient mûri
collectivement
est-ce que sur ce point là c'est à dire
le changement notre de notre modèle
penser qu'on peut faire en sorte que les
citoyens participent à ce changement
par ailleurs l'avant projet de loi porte
résolument sur les dimensions
domestiques de la question or beaucoup
d'aspects de cette problématique
sont également internationaux et
notamment européens
je pense bien sûr à la taxation
kérosène pour les vols internationaux
les normes environnementales pour les
véhicules les verdissement du transport
maritime transport routier etc
d'après vous comment faire pour que les
travaux de la convention pèse également
à l'échelle européenne
je vous remercie pour vos réponses merci
je vais j'ai quand même donné la parole
à philippe tabarot parce que comme il
est rapporteur sur servi au transport et
aux îles je pense qu'il est bête dans le
même registre
filipe silva je vais enchaîner sur sur
la question de notre époque et par
l'esprit de la mission transport
marchandises qui nous a réunis à pour
trois auditions avec avait été un des
points trop bien sûr aider les collègues
y lire nous avons 10 youn et des
transporteurs de marchandises qui nous
ont pas vu une de bonne foi qui ont paru
a pris conscience de la situation
écologique et montrer leur volonté de
décarboner après nous on dit un certain
nombre de choses et nous ont dit qu'ils
pensaient qu'il ya une énergie propre
adaptée à leur type d'activité notamment
pour trouver demandé en puissance
on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui de
l'hydrogène ils ont été amusés de voir
les décisions que le gouvernement
présente deux lances pour l'hydrogène
pour pour cette année au pour l'année
prochaine alors que dans le cadre de
leurs activités pour l'hydrogène
cc c'est très loin deuxièmement ils ont
considéré qu'il y avait de production
suffisantes notamment sur notre
continent de matériel pour permettre le
renouvellement 7 de cette flotte qui
doit être particulièrement conséquente
chaque année pour pour la décarbonés
comme vous l'imaginez et troisièmement
ils nous disent que leur modèle
économique ne supportera pas certain
nombre de décisions qui sont entrés lui
soit par la convention soit dans le
cadre du projet doit notamment sur une
hausse supplémentaire de là
des cpe de manière plus générale est un
peu dans le sens de la question de notre
collègue écoles bonne foi ne pensez vous
pas que certaines d'autres oppositions
ne sont pas applicables notamment à des
citoyens de bonne foi et qu'il peut
faire quelque chose pour la protection
de la planète
d'un côté mais qui souhaite quand même
temps 24 heures leur colis à la zone
soit libre et et gratuitement
merci je vous donne la parole pour
apporter une réponse à ces séries
question je suis sûr que jean pierre
cabrol eux aussi sur certaines enfin le
encore une fois ce sont les auteurs de
ces mesures
alors oui c'est vrai les questions de
madame comme celle de renan dans cacao
au fort économiquement qu'est ce que ça
veut dire toutes ces mesures et vous
avez raison de poser la question d'abord
est-ce que du point de vue du climat et
c'est vrai que l'on revient aujourd'hui
à à ce que nous devons faire en plus
pourquoi c'est que en 2020 si l'union
européenne abe a changé son objectif de
qui était de 40 - 40 %
c'était la proposition 2015 et qu'elles
étaient relevées à 2020 c'est que en
2020 tous les pays s'étaient c'est
l'accord de paris devait revenir avec
des propositions plus plus raccord plus
cohérente avec l'objectif de limitation
des températures à moins de 2 degrés ou
éventuellement possiblement même si la
fenêtre est très étroite
il faut le reconnaître afin de réunir et
de ce point de vue donc c'est ça ça tout
le monde le sait tout le savez
d'ailleurs la france s'est battu pour
qu'on ait un objectif plus ambitieux
pour 2030
donc il ya déjà ce premier problème
c'est effectivement il ya un décalage
aujourd'hui entre la stratégie nationale
bas carbone pour 2030 ce qui a été
demandé aux citoyens et le renforcement
donc on a annoncé 100 en 2020 et en 2021
à glasgow on va expliquer comment on va
faire comment on va faire pour arriver à
ce d'abord avec un nouvel objectif
national
alors je c'est toujours très difficile
parce que évidemment tout se tient
j'entends avec cette réflexion sur le
transport des marchandises
il n'y a pas de solution magique sur le
il ya plusieurs solutions bien sûr la
question des équipements
il ya un débat sur est ce que vraiment
on va pouvoir aujourd'hui ne rien faire
sur les camions ou quand même en fait
faire beaucoup et il ya tout un débat il
ya cinq ans on aurait dit le camion
électrique ça n'existe pas il y en a
déjà qui roule c'est encore cher c'est
encore un peu loin mais c'est en train
d'arriver comment penser à qui a cinq
ans de dire qu'en 2030 ou en 2022 20 le
prix de la voiture électrique qui serait
compétitif avec le prix de la voiture à
essence personne n'y pensais c'est juste
parce qu'à une accélération du progrès
technologique parce qu'il ya des
indicateurs de politiques économiques
qui font que l'économie réelle suis ou
se transforment c'est pour ça que
l'évaluation quantitative et elle est
forcément plus systémique c'est en c'est
jean pierre cabrol l'a rappelé il faut
vraiment faire quelque chose sur le
transport il faut faire quelque chose
sur l'agriculture c'est difficile c'est
aussi très systémique c'est pas plus
maître d'essence sur les tracteurs c'est
plein de choses qui peuvent faire que
l'agriculture deviennent au contraire
d'ailleurs un facteur positif de la
lutte contre le changement climatique et
non pas un secteur m internet
et pareil pour le par le bâtiment
donc qu'est ce qu'il ya comme scénario
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas beaucoup parce
que la plupart je veux pas être trop
technique mais la plupart des modèles
économiques qui essayait de comprendre
qu'elle allait être l'impact des mesures
de lutte contre le changement climatique
il ya une première génération de modèles
qui essayait de mesurer le coût est
d'abord évidemment le coût le plus bas
est d'arbitrer entre le coût et le
résultat donc au fond comme on optimise
le coup de la réduction de la tonne de
carbone
ces modèles
en fait en gros défaut c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont en train d'être maintenant
abandonner c'est que il faisait comme
s'il n'y avait pas de coût du changement
climatique c'est à dire qu'il y avait
pas de problème de des maisons dans le
cordon littoral qui avait pas de dégâts
des tempêtes sur les centrales
électriques etc etc
et du coup on s'est vu une espèce de
contradiction entre des modèles qui
disait il vaut mieux ne rien faire et
attendre que l'on soit plus riches dans
15 ans 20 ans 30 ans et à ce moment là
on aura probablement les solutions et
les évaluations des coûts non pas futur
mais déjà actuelle j'ai plus les
chiffres en tête de ce que les
compagnies d'assurance ont publié cette
année mais il se trouve que dans
certains pays maintenant des compagnies
d'assurances refusent d'assurer les
risques climatiques parce que c'est
juste trop cher donc la tradition des
modèles a du coup changé et en se disant
si on se place en 2050 et annette 0
qu'est-ce qu'il faut qu'on fasse d'où
cette analyse un des secteurs et aux
fonds qu'elles sont qu'elle est un peu
le résultat économique
on est en plein démarrage de ces
scénarios est en tout cas pour la france
il ya eu un certain nombre d'études
la plupart qui ont été menées par le
cabinet de consultation ernst young qui
a montré qu'en fait alors je vais
prendre deux exemples celui des
enseignes ou qui dit il ya un potentiel
de création d'emplois effectivement et
donc au contraire d'une avec un taux de
croissance qui est celui qu'on peut
espérer un bon alors selon qu'on est
optimiste mais optimiste sur la relance
économique après la crise qu vide
si on suit on tourne autour des
instincts de 2% de croissance par an de
croissance potentielle on peut avoir le
même taux de croissance ou peut-être
plus élevé avec une un basculement de
l'investissement verse donc ces trois
secteurs de l'investissement vert et
donc en détaillant les secteurs où on
crée des emplois
ça veut pas dire qu'on n'en perd pas
dans d'autres secteurs ou pia pas des
changements très importants apportés
nokia évidemment un tout le coup de
compensation de transition
professionnelle de nouveaux équipements
puisque c est qui
comment par exemple de camions même si
la flotte change très souvent vous avez
raison mais ce sénateur
c'est un secteur où le l'équipement il
faut le renouveler très fréquemment ce
qui est d'ailleurs au fond une chance
mais c'est vrai que sa dépouille et donc
il faut effectivement penser que le
aller vers une économie décarbonée et
c'est d'abord un investissement d'abord
en capital important et aussi en
accompagnement social je pense aller fin
il ya plein d'exemples aujourd'hui sur
la fermeture d'une mine de charbon en
allemagne en espagne et au fond comment
gérer ça donc pour l'instant ce que nous
disent les économistes qui sait
qu'aujourd'hui
étant donné les innovations
technologiques qui sont maintenant en
train de se dette remue re hydrogène
n'étant pas dans ce cas là encore parce
que ça c'est quand même encore un peu
loin même s'il ya des trains à hydrogène
qui circulent déjà en allemagne il ya
des camions hydrogène qui circulent déjà
aussi enfin c'est pas non plus 2 c'est
pas 2050 la technologie c'est plutôt
dans les dix prochaines années
il ya gagne quand même une interrogation
parce que il faut que en face à cet
effort d'investissement parce que si
c'est juste corriger pas des instruments
fiscaux
on n'y arrive pas c'est ça va trop
lentement c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
sinon il faudrait augmenter une taxe
carbone très très fort je vous rappelle
en suède mais parce que ils ont fait une
réforme fiscale ya 30 ans très profonde
et qu' ils peuvent supporter ce taux de
carbone qui leur permet d'ailleurs de
décarbonés d'industrie lourde un très
intéressant
en suède on a lancé les premières usines
de fabrication d'acier à zéro carbone
donc le secteur pompes en ce moment on
peut pas y toucher
donc ça va venir sur le ciment etc donc
on est en plein réflexion il ya des
traditions économiques différentes
ni nicolas stern
l'économiste du climat très connu dit et
en plus c'est illusoire de penser qu'on
peut continuer la croissance si on
n'arrive pas à décarbonés parce que tout
simplement le coût du changement
climatique
jean pierre cabrol à dans certaines
régions mais aussi en france
ça va être juste trop élevé donc on aura
des pertes en capital d'infrastructures
et je le vois je le vois dans certaines
régions notamment les petites îles qui
sont les plus affectées déjà par le
changement climatique dont pour elle
c'est maintenant du tout en paie à
l'autre
l'investissement sur les routes les
points les voies ferrées il est détruit
par les tempêtes donc les pays s'endette
pour pouvoir financer c'est normal leurs
investissements et avant même qu'ils
aient vraiment pu rembourser le capital
et détruit donc à une à une
appauvrissement du capital notamment
techniques et d'infrastructures et je ne
parle pas du capital social les maisons
détruites va donc là et ça dans le
raisonnement économique parce que c'est
du long terme
c'est très difficile donc on se bat
beaucoup dans la profession qui a bien
d'ailleurs pour savoir combien c'est
très très clair dans le plan de relance
est honnie au niveau européen est ce que
ça vaut le coup de tout mettre du plan
de relance dans des activités qui déjà
génère la transition ou est ce qu'il
vaut mieux on l'a vu sur la discussion
sur renault sur la france
bon c'est des choix politique compliquée
un personne n'a la recette mais ce que
il ya vraiment des scénarios aujourd'hui
de plus en plus nombreux et peut tout à
fait vos communautés ceux qui ont été
publiés pour la france mais aussi pour
certains pays européens où on a un taux
de croissance en tout cas similaire à
celui qu'on espère avoir après la crise
et et une croissance qui elle permet
d'aller vers à ce calcul de réduction
des émissions d'ici 2050
bon alors et du coup mais on a besoin
d'un énorme énorme effort de recherche
et de et de débats entre des économies
cela dessus d'ailleurs ma fondation
financent le plus possible scénario
pourquoi
on y retrouve quelque chose sur le volet
européen des importations je suis
peut-être un petit peu moins pessimiste
que ronan dantec c'est vrai que tous les
sujets habitat transports transports
sont de la politique domestique un
l'europe sa finance ça produit d'énormes
et après des gens les applique comme ils
veulent mais je vois quand même une
grande convergence sur les modèles
commandés carbone le transport privé
aujourd'hui il ya plus de questions
tout le monde va aller vers
l'électrification plus ou moins vite et
donc le problème c'est le réseau
électrique et les infrastructures de
bornes mais on va plus loin aujourd'hui
à regarder les réflexions sur les villes
européennes en particulier c'est la
voiture c'est bien mais en même temps il
ya ce problème de la pollution de l'air
et de l'espace public et donc on est en
train de réfléchir tout toutes les
villes européennes sont dans les mêmes
affres parce que évidemment c'est pas
facile sur comment on enlève les
voitures ou est ce qu'on les réserves
est-ce qu'on a des transports de
substitution personnes dans la recette
miracle mais je vois que dans toutes les
villes européennes
c'est la discussion est ouverte milan
florence val était partie de notre union
mais enfin il continue à y penser
donc je vois quand même malgré la
spécificité des politiques domestiques
une grande convergence sur à quoi ça
doit ressembler et d'ailleurs je pense
que je sors de mon rôle un green deal
français c'est le moment d'y réfléchir à
quoi ça va ressembler et je trouve que
du coup on a une commission européenne
qui parce qu'elle réfléchisse sur ce
green deal sur tous les secteurs
je crois que ça va être beaucoup plus
intéressant que de réfléchir seulement
aux tonnes de carbone enfin avec une
préoccupation uniquement climat
puisqu'il faut qu on ait quelque chose
de plus large et du coup je vois bien
que sur les chaînes de valeur
internationale et ça comporte évidemment
cette question du transport just in time
y'a pas bon il ya il ya bien sûr la
déforestation il ya plein de dimension
mais il ya aussi le fait que dans le
moment où nous nous sommes la
relocalisation de certaines chaînes de
valeur paraît
importante du point de vue vous avez
certainement écouter et participer à ce
débat sur la souveraineté économique
européenne ou nationale dont on voit
bien l'enjeu de se rendre plus
indépendants des chaînes de valeur qui
veut dire aussi certaines
transformations technologiques
on le voit elles sont à l'heure et aussi
des décisions sur abandonné le colis
amazon dans la journée ça va pas aller
ça peut pas exercer peut pas fonctionner
en même temps iliad il ya des choix à
faire et ces choix peuvent être tout à
fait débattu et on peut pas à la fois
favoriser le commerce de proximité dans
le centre des villes pour les
revitaliser et se dire qu'après tout la
seule solution c'est amazon et le colis
dans la journée il va falloir faire des
choix et ça ça c'est un choix de société
de débats police donc je trouve que
alors cette question du transport de
marchandises et passionnant d'abord
parce qu'on avait l'impression que
c'était impossible d'y toucher
moi je vois quand même dans la réflexion
européenne qui était compétition à
outrance mauvaises conditions de travail
de beaucoup de salariés dans ce secteur
quelque chose qui se dit quand même on a
un atout en europe c'est la connectivité
des territoires et après tout est ce
qu'on ne va pas se relancer dans un
grand effort de l'infrastructure
ferroviaire européenne
je pense que c'est le moment
technologiquement du point de vue
industriel et du point de vue de la
santé la pollution de tous par ailleurs
alors il ya un autre modèle alternatif
on le voit aux états unis monsieur elon
musk là qui fait des titres parce qu'il
a doublé sa fortune en donnant la chance
il paris il a paris sur le camion
électrique et il m'a alors est-ce que
quels sont les effets en d2 c'est
comment on fait beau mais on voit que il
ya une plaine il ya en étant lan
explosion de le transport ne sera plus
comme avant
donc est ce que nous la france l'europe
paris d'abord sur le ferroviaire dont on
qui très compliqué on le sait
beaucoup plus experts comment là dessus
et je me souviens quand j'étais à
matignon les les pessimisme de savoir
miaule sur le report modal
mais en même temps on a une évolution
technologique qui arrive est un
il faut de toute façon et je crois que
les transporteurs c'est normal qu'ils
disent qu'ils peuvent passer tout à fait
logique
tous les secteurs il travaille tous les
jours
c'est comme de dire aux pêcheurs que
tout le monde défend l'activité qui sont
tant qu'il est en train de faire même
s'ils voient les changements nécessaires
mais c'est pour ça qu'il faut un
accompagnement non seulement de
régulation on va avoir des normes sur
les camions assez sévères d'ici le mois
de juin 2021
puisque la le la prochaine étape de la
mise en place du green deal c'est quand
même des la sévérisation des normes sur
les transports y compris des transports
de marchandises dont l'aller retour
entre investissement et régulation est
en train de se faire parce que on a ce
cadre européen pour finir de répondre un
roman dont tête qui nous oblige à
converger les voies peuvent être
différentes mais il ya une voie
européenne certainement de transfert
modal et une voix européenne aussi de
technologies
peut-être que l'hydrogène est trop loin
peut-être que la batterie des tris pour
les camions va aller plus vite mais il
ya une réflexion mais de toute façon
comme pour les voitures individuelles la
sévérisation des normes va faire bouger
le secteur de toute façon donc voilà
j'étais un petit peu longue et merci
pour vos excellente question
ses paroles oui merci je veux bien agir
sur plusieurs points la première c'est
de rappeler
sa part est du moins ce que je vais vous
dire mais dans tout changement qui n'est
pas une volonté naturel chez l'homme il
ya une période de transition qu'on n'a
pas vécu jusqu'à présent donc et c'est
malheureusement la période la plus
difficile donc qu'il ya des efforts qui
sont à réaliser et cette période de
transition est nécessaire pour pouvoir
acquérir un minimum d'expérience cirque
aujourd'hui les solutions et je reviens
sur le transport en terme de déplacement
est ce que c'est les criquets ce que
c'est l'hydrogène ou autre chose demain
on n'en sait rien on n'a pas vécu
donc il faut commencer par ça et essai
et c'est donc impérieux est nécessaire
de le faire le plus tôt possible
il ya une évidence qui est sorti au togo
au cours de cette convention c'est que
le modèle sociétal d'aujourd'hui
fonctionnait plus c'est là qu'on a pu la
capacité c'est terminé on a bien vécu
jusqu'à présent mais d'acheter trois
quatre téléphones parents de se déplacer
comme on le souhaite avec le véhicule
qu'on souhaite de d'habiter dans une
grande maison avec un terrain immense
voile à émettre du gaz à effet de serre
de co2 c'est pas anormal en soit ce qui
est essentiel c'est de ne pas trop en
maîtres mais surtout d'avoir de la
capacité de stockage et je vous parle de
ça puisque je faisais partie du groupe
habitat enfin plutôt se loger au sein de
la convention on l'appeler comme ça l'a
détruit tous les deux ans l'équivalent
d'un département
c'est autant de capacité de stockage de
carbone en moins
l'agriculture c'est pain et le fait de
cultiver à outrance les terres
c'est émettre du co2 et c'est également
ce coupé de capacité de stockage assez
de points que je voulais rappeler et je
voudrais revenir sur la partie transport
la partie transport je transporte tous
les mois 500 tonnes de matières
plastiques par camion essentiellement et
par camion en moyenne en charge entre je
vais dire 20 et 22 tonnes de matière je
crois qu'il faut faire un distinguo
entre le transport aux industriels et le
transport aux particuliers on n'est pas
sur le même type de véhicule et donc a
priori la technologie futur ne sera pas
forcément la même peut-être
qu'effectivement sur la partie transport
routier de
aux industrielles pour desservir des
études des industriels pardon il s'agit
de s'orienter vers l'hydrogène j'en sais
rien je suis pas technicien et c'est
peut-être la solution de demain faut
faire des essais mais ce qui est certain
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la technologie qui
est apportée et qui fonctionne aux
particuliers pour livrer les colis
amazon balle électriques fonctionnent
très bien on est en regroupement on est
on est sur des plates formes de
regroupement de ces colis et ses colis
sont ensuite distribués sur un secteur
défini aux particuliers donc
l'électrique fonctionne très bien sur la
partie des coûts mais effectivement le
matériel le remplacer ça représente des
coûts importants je connais pas
précisément la valeur d'un camion mais
j'imagine que ça doit être relativement
important
c'est un métier qui doit vivre une
véritable mutation et c'est ce que je
visais la période de transition passe
par des efforts par des mutations dans
les différents métiers dans mon métier
je l' ai vécu à une époque la
récupération c'était aller offrir du
service un industriel en particulier
pour l'ex est devenu un marché mondial
est tellement important en terme de
quantité qu'il a fallu s'organiser entre
des prestataires de service des
industriels qui régénérer les matières
et d'autres professionnels qui les
vendaient c'est un peu pareil dans ton
sport dans le transport aujourd'hui on
assiste à une bagarre de prix c'est
phénoménal
moi je met en concurrence régulièrement
tous les mois des transporteurs directes
ou des affréteurs et parfois des
affréteurs secondes à chaque des
transporteurs c'est un métier assez
compliqué que je ne ferais pas
d'ailleurs mais je crois qu'ils aient
effectivement malheureusement une
mutation profonde à apporter dans ce
métier j'ai pas de réflexion
particulière et j'ai pas de solution à
proposer
mais il ya des choix qu'il faut accepter
et il ya des mutations qui va falloir
accepter le transport à partir au mans
et coûte plus cher dans mon métier c'est
pas un problème en soi c'est à dire que
ce coût à la tonne
plus cher je vais leur porter à l'achat
ou à la vente de mon produit c'est comme
ça que ça fonctionne et à partir du
moment où tous les industriels du
transport sont d'accord sur des tarifs
j'ai pas de souci majeur pour le faire
voilà merci merci pour pour ses
explications merci pour ces réponses
alors on a encore j'ai encore douze
demandes de parole donc je vais
regrouper faire des séries de six jeunes
à parole à stéphane demi merci monsieur
le président merci à vous deux pour pour
vos interventions
à titre personnel j'étais assez
dubitatif vis-à-vis de la convention
citoyenne j'ai trouvé que c'était un
gadget un peu dingo mais avec un peu de
recul et notamment avec la la commission
d'aujourd'hui je trouve que ça montre au
moins l'intérêt de rencontrer des gens
intéressants je voudrais vous remercier
vraiment pour pour vos propos merci jeu
en vous écoutant tous les deux je me
dise je me rappelais un ancien
enseignant qui me disait quand on ne
veut pas entendre et je trouve que là
par le biais de cette convention au mais
les questions sur la table et on est
obligé d'y apporter une réponse c'est
d'ailleurs le danger de cette de cet
exercice de démocratie participative
le président longeole a dit avec la
diplomatie qui qui tient à sa fonction
le projet de loi issu des propositions
de la convention dévoilé par le
gouvernement le 8 janvier dernier a
suscité de la déception il marque un
recul par rapport aux mesures de la
convention citoyenne des propositions
brillent par leur absence comme
l'obligation de rénovation thermique des
logements
vous avez parlé ou l'interdiction de
coupe rase des forêts alors qu'elle
avait été plébiscitée par par les
citoyens les mesures de ce projet de loi
ne font pas l'objet d'évaluations
thématique détaillé il faudrait pourtant
que les autres hypothèses de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
soient claires mesurable pédagogique et
transparente et j'en viens à ma question
une question sur
ce que j'appellerais la communication
motivationnelle vis-à-vis de nos
citoyens comment mettre en place un
processus visible et lisible
d'évaluation de ces différentes mesures
pour tenter de déclencher un véritable
sentiment d'appropriation individuel
responsable et motivant de cet objectif
collectif
pour le dire autrement et de façon plus
intellectuelle comment transformer ce
drame maquereau en véritable implication
micro merci je donne la parole aux
savoyards de services / ils peuvent à si
monsieur le président madame messieurs
les coprésidents votre rapport
recommandant une réduction de l'impact
neiges énergétique du secteur du
bâtiment notamment par le biais de la
rénovation c'est un sujet qui ne
touchent entre savoirs bien évidemment
nous sommes nombreux à partager ce
constat et cet objectif a été l'un des
points d'orgue du plan de relance mis en
place par le gouvernement
de nombreuses mesures allant en ce sens
ont été intégrées au projet de loi de
finances en 2021
voici avez vous pu vous pencher sur ces
nouvelles mesures et c'était le cas vous
semble-t-elle insatisfaisante
quelles seraient les points à améliorer
pour atteindre un niveau de réduction
suffisant par ailleurs la question du
des financements des mesures que vous
avez proposé se posant monsieur blanchet
rapporteur général la convention
citoyenne au climat avait indiqué lors
d'une précédente audition à l'assemblée
nationale que la finance ne faisait pas
partie de votre mission
même si vous n'avez pas eu le même si
vous avez eu l'opportunité de l'aborder
à quelques reprises dans votre rapport
le fait que ce sujet n'ait pas été
étudiée plus en profondeur sont pourtant
dommageable comment peut-on réfléchir à
des mesures sans évaluer l'impact
financier pour l'état et des ménages et
la façon dont elles doivent être
financés est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'elle
quelque chose qui vous a frustré lors de
votre travail sur la convention
pensez vous que ce manque est la raison
pour laquelle plusieurs des mesures que
vous avez proposées ont été modifiées ou
refusée par le gouvernement dans le
projet de loi qui a récemment été rendu
public merci merci je vais la parole à
angèle préville merci monsieur le
président merci à vous deux pour
l'éclairage sur cette convention
citoyenne pour le climat alors je suis
d'accord avec vous qu'on est loin de
faire
de faire les efforts pour réduire les
gaz à effet de serre surtout qu'on l'a
pas mentionné mais va se rajouter un
problème supplémentaire c'est que nous
allons avoir avec le réchauffement
climatique la fusion du permafrost avec
du dégagement de méthane qui est un gaz
encore plus puissant
concernant l'effet de serre je vous ai
bien écouter et ça m'a semblé être très
intéressant ce que vous avez vécu dans
cette convention citoyenne et notamment
quelque chose qui me tient beaucoup à
coeur parce que j'ai été professeur
l'information et l'information qui vous
a été faite et qui a permis de réaliser
ce qu'elle ait changement climatique
et justement je voulais vous demander
comment pourrait-on faire pour que
puisque vous êtes tous arrivés
visiblement sans avoir pour vous aviez
une idée sans doute peut-être du
réchauffement climatique mais sans avoir
une idée précise des de tout de toutes
les conséquences que cela pouvait avoir
est compris dans nos dans nos vies
personnelles
comment pourrait-on faire et quelles
sont les idées et éventuellement vous
auriez pour qu'on puisse communiquer et
au sujet des efforts qu'il faudrait
faire est ce que nous avons fait jusqu'à
présent beaucoup d'efforts je parle de
manière générale est ce que la question
du modèle économique n'est pas une
question auquel on va se heurter
et puis je voulais vous demander aussi à
monsieur cabrol puisque vous avez l'air
d'être passionné
si c'est le cas de de tous les citoyens
qui étaient là et comment vous avez
échangé
est ce que il ya une espèce de consensus
qui est qui est sorti de là avec une
assemblée qui était donc tout concerné
par le sujet vraiment et puis dernière
chose quand vous avez mentionné mme
tubiana on décale dans le temps mais
finalement on n'a pas le temps je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous et
notamment aussi sur la la stratégie
nationale bas carbone qui n'est pas la
fin et de vous de tous les mini ça nous
nous sommes rendu compte et notamment
quand nous portons des amendements sur
la précarité énergétique et sur la
nécessité d'aller beaucoup plus vite et
beaucoup plus fort sur les rénovations
thermiques et nous
pourtant allée des avis défavorables
voilà je vous remercie
merci je vais pas vendre la marque de
ces drac
merci monsieur le président merci madame
tu bien à monsieur cabrol d'être avec
nous ce matin je salue profondément le
travail qui a été effectué par la
convention citoyenne
bien qu' il y ait quelques aspects qui
me laisse encore interrogative donc je
pense que la réunion de ce matin nous
permettra peut-être de en tout cas pour
ma part d'enlever certains je ne vais
pas revenir sur parce que il ya beaucoup
de questions qui me viennent à l'esprit
mais à la lecture de votre travail
certains pans en fait un de la
transition écologique semble moins
traités en tout cas moins évoquée dans
le travail dans le rapport définitif
alors que il me semble qu'ils sont
primordiaux le président lugo a évoqué
évidemment le travail que nous avions
nous-mêmes effectué au sénat autour de
l'empreinte environnementale du
numérique
mais moi je ne vais pas revenir là
dessus je voudrais vous en poser sur un
autre sujet qui est la question
énergétique tout simplement si plusieurs
mesures se concentre sur laval et la
phase de consommation les moyens de
produire deux productions sont en
réalité très peu évoquée dans vos
travaux
alors que c'est un aspect essentiel si
l'on souhaite atteindre la neutralité
carbone comme cela a été déjà rappelé à
la fois dans vos propos et dans les
questions de mes collègues
donc ma première question est en réalité
qu'est ce qui a poussé la convention
citoyenne à ne pas investir pleinement
ce terrain là et du coup ça m'amène une
deuxième question est ce que vous aviez
eu tous les moyens nécessaires pour
réaliser finalement le chiffrage en
empreinte carbone de vos propositions
puisqu'on a on a évoqué des pistes mais
en réalité on n'a pas de quantité on n'a
pas de chiffrage précis là-dessus pour
justement atteindre tous ces objectifs
et donc si vous avez eu ces moyens-là
lesquels sont ils en réalité est ce que
vous pourriez nous éclairer sur ce point
là je vous remercie
merci la parole est à mme monsieur de
villaz merci monsieur le président merci
madame pu bignan tubes y en a et
cabrol pour votre présence parmi nous et
puis je voudrais vous remercier d'avoir
pris donner de votre temps pour
participer à un exercice dit de
démocratie participative et je voudrais
moi bénéficier de votre éclairage
puisque vous avez réfléchi à cette
question sur 3 comment le premier alors
le savoyard que je suis qui vit à oui
encore et qui vit sur la métropole de
lyon qui s'est exilé sur la métropole de
llo constate que quand on regarde les
effets des particules fines sur le
problème de la santé notamment auprès
des plus jeunes de notre population en
dix ans les problèmes pulmonaires ont
augmenté plus de plus de 20%
donc c'est un problème réel et tout à
l'heure madame tu viens à vous avez dit
choix partagés et donc non comme ya
nécessité d'aller vers une zone à faible
émission et comment concilier cette
orientation dans une agglomération comme
la nôtre sans chasser ou exclure les
foyers les plus modestes de nos centres
villes qui n'ont pas forcément les
moyens du jour au lendemain de changer
leur voiture qui sont souvent les plus
polluantes
la deuxième question j'ai été président
pendant quelques années d'un grand parc
de 2400 hectares qui accueillait le cndd
il dimanche
chaque jour 50 mille sites ada et
j'avais la problématique de la
protection de la biodiversité des
écosystèmes sur ce compact et surtout
notamment tout ce qu'on appelle zones
sèches et jose et demi j'ai fait appel
aux services de l'état et je me suis
rendu compte que ses services n'avaient
pas forcément les moyens de mettre en
oeuvre et de contrôler
d'où une question comment se donner les
moyens de nos politiques publiques
ambitieuses en matière protection de
l'environnement dans le projet de loi
c'est mon troisième comment on aborde la
question de l'article l'artiste la
ratification des sols sur le département
où je vis actuellement plus de 50% mais
je crois que c'est une règle on
n'échappe pas à une règle générale de
nos agriculteurs d'ici cinq ans vont
prendre leur retraite
et quand quatre jeunes viennent à
l'agriculture 3 ne viennent pas du monde
agricole médullienne doute mois entre
l'artistique à l'actif ication des sols
et je me pose la question comment lui
aussi cette question à la nécessaire
réflexion sur une loi foncière pour
faciliter la transmission des terres
agricoles
voilà mes trois questions comment en fin
d'année on va avoir va se tenir la coop
26 et je voudrais savoir ce que vous en
attendez merci merci alors pour terminer
cette série de questions je donne la
parole à madame st pée merci monsieur le
président bonjour à toutes et tous
madame la co présidente monsieur le
coprésident merci pour votre présence ce
matin parmi nous ma question s'inscrire
à un peu dans le prolongement de la
question de martha de sidrac à savoir
que dans le rapport final de la
convention citoyenne vous ne mentionnez
que marginalement la méthanisation
sans vraiment évoqué l'utilité que peut
remplir le biogaz dans la transition
écologique
or cette énergique et le biogaz elle
n'est pas intermittente
contrairement à l'éolien au
photovoltaïque
cette énergie valorise les territoires
de france et cette énergie coûtent peu
cher au consommateur et madame la
présidente je
j'ai vu parce que vous l'avez dit dans
votre propos introductif vous êtes quand
même très sensible aux 14 millions de
précaires que nous avons actuellement en
france et je crois que tout cela doit
guider aussi de votre réflexion dans ma
question est claire pourquoi dans votre
rapport avec vous cet apparent de
réserves quant au biogaz et je considère
pour ma part que nous avons le devoir de
réussir aussi l'acceptabilité sociale de
notre mutation écologique et énergétique
je vous remercie
merci qui commence plutôt bien
monsieur oui il ya beaucoup de questions
sur l'évaluation à des mesures et que ça
n'est pas mon rôle est assurée celle des
citoyens
je proposerai que jean pierre cabrol
commence et puis je je je bouclerais sur
les éléments qui sont plus de mon
ressort très bien avec plaisir l enjeu
sur 30 dans l'ordre il y avait une
première question sur la rénovation de
l'habitat et les mesures qui avaient été
prises
de votre part celle de plus le sénateur
excusez moi et vous avez posé une
deuxième question que j'ai pas eu le
temps de noter qu on y reviendra
peut-être après sur la rénovation de
l'habitat et donc c'est un sujet se
connaît bien puisque effectivement je
faisais partie du groupe seloger on a
écrit dans notre rapport à la nécessité
de rénover obligatoirement l'intégralité
des habitations
on a défini des seuils il existe
aujourd'hui des seuils a b c d e f g /
pour définir le critère de de conformité
de l'habitation
donc il nous est apparu évident au
travail qui est effectivement rénové en
global avait plus d'efficacité
d'une part parce qu'effectivement le
résultat est immédiat et seconde mans le
dimensionnement des travaux qui sont
arrivés est en fait ensemble permettent
plus d'efficacité son résultat final est
attendue dans le projet doit on n'en
parle pas effectivement puisque sa
touche aujourd'hui on a plusieurs
catégories on a on a des catégories
d'habitation or que ce soit des
propriétaires occupants des
propriétaires bailleurs en sentant
qu'ils sont ce qu'on appelle des
passoires thermiques et aujourd'hui on
s'est aperçu en travaillant sujet qu'il
fallait rénover pour être dans les clous
cinq cent mille logements par an à
minima ce qui représente un peu d'argent
enfants et je crois que c'est là où le
bât blesse
puisqu'on parle sur dix ans 250
milliards qu'il faut or 150 milliards
c'est le coût des travaux s'est pas le
coût des subventions qui sont adonnés
soit bien d'accord
par contre ce qui est évident c'est que
je les dis au départ dans mon
introduction
la partie habitat c'est 25% des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre donc
ça paraît quand même assez essentiel et
je vois moi autour de chez moi
on est dans une situation particulière
de la vallée de larmes il ya encore
beaucoup de chauffage au fioul il ya
encore beaucoup de cheminée qui sont pas
flamme verte c'est-à-dire qu'ils
polluent énormément
donc tout ça sont des coups on estime à
peu près le coût moyen d'une rénovation
de la rénovation des habitats
est de l'ordre de
quarante cinquante mille euros donc
effectivement c'est problématique pour
les foyers les plus modestes
mais c'est pas impossible et puis comme
je disais au départ la période de
transition est nécessaire et l'effort
est nécessaire aujourd'hui puisque
demain ça sera un peu plus pire est donc
forcément un peu plus coûteux
vous aviez une deuxième question alors
sur la partie habitat enfermé dotation
globale journée juste finir sur un point
c'est les mesures que l'on avait écrite
quand c'est commencer par faire un
diagnostic de ce qu'il est nécessaire de
faire c'est choisir des artisans qui
sont conformes et ont souhaité au
maximum travailler avec des artisans
locaux et les circuits courts au niveau
des matériaux pour limiter l'impact
carbone
et puis c'est suivre le travaux se faire
qu il faut organiser un travail entre
tous ces artisans et puis à la fin de
ces travaux faire un constat de ce qui a
été fait est constatée oui ou non si on
était dans les clous donc c'est pour ça
qu'on avait écrit toute une série de
mesures sur sur les guichet unique qui
nous apparaissait c'est essentiel qui
est une mesure interdépendantes de la
manne ovation global donc aujourd'hui
c'est pas actée par le gouvernement je
sais pas où on en est on à il y un
comité de pilotage qui est organisée par
le patron de choix de la caisse des
dépôts et consignations pour trouver des
systèmes de financement possibles voilà
je sais pas plus d'informations si ce
n'est qu'on est en cours de travail etc
aujourd'hui rien n'est acté dans la loi
vous aviez une deuxième question que je
n'ai pas pris le temps que j'ai pas pu
me de noter c'est par rapport au
financement qui faisait pas partie de la
mission et si ça crée pas justement des
frustrations et également que des
mesures ont été enlevés entre aux
propositions le projet de loi par manque
de financement ouais ça c'est une
certitude
donc ça faisait pas partie de la mission
et puis le temps même si ça faisait
partie de la mission
le temps nous aurait manqué
le travail était assez important on a
passé cette session ça représente quand
même neuf mois de travail
on n'avait pas le temps de travailler
dessus effectivement la partie
financement surtout par rapport aux
sommes dont on parle il faut avoir un
minimum de connaissances sur le sujet on
a émis des pistes possibles pour
récupérer de l'argent auprès auprès
voilà pour pour permettre ces
financements mais est d aider ces foyers
les plus modestes mais on n'est pas allé
très loin effectivement et en concernant
la réduction des mesures dans le projet
de loi il ya enfin moi je suis pas
politique dont je sais pas la façon dont
ça se passe entre les différents
ministères concernés au sein du
gouvernement mais j'imagine que chacun
ferrat et par rapport à son territoire
etc entre l'économie et le mt ça n'a pas
toujours été évident donc je suppose que
effectivement des mesures ne sont pas
passés par manque de financement ou par
priorités budgétaires
je n'ai pas plus d'informations sur ce
sujet et je voulais revenir sur le
ensuite une autre question qui était
comment communiquer sur le climat et les
les gaz à effet de serre c'est ce que je
disais au départ effectivement on avait
un petit peu de notions du climat mais
encore une fois ça s'arrête au bout de
notre jardin c'est à dire que tous les
jours ça changeait pas nous devions
commencer on continue à prendre de
voitures diesel ou essence avec plus ou
moins de chevaux et puis on allait
s'acheter un téléphone portable quand on
avait envie bon bref c'est c'est rien ne
change dans le puits traditionnels
al'inverse après avoir participé à la
convention citoyenne sur le climat c'est
à profondément impacté nos vies à tous
comment communiquer et je pense que
c'est un élément essentiel je pense que
tout français capables de comprendre ce
qu'il est nécessaire de faire pour le
bien être de tous et les générations
futures
on a pensé nous a déclaré bones corps
sur les produits donc je crois que ça
fait partie des mesures entre france
relance le plan france relance et le le
projet de loi climat mais ça me paraît
indispensable de communiquer sur le
sujet et puis par ailleurs moi j'ai un
souvenir quand j'étais tout petit il y
avait une pub qui passait à la télé
régulièrement qu'ils étaient on voyait
des gens qui jeter leurs déchets par la
fenêtre c'était le début où on partait
en congé on partait en vacances assez
facilement la voiture se démocratiser et
tous les gens roulaient tous les
week-ends et aux grandes vacances est en
général vous voyez les gens vider leur
cendrier par la fenêtre
jeter leurs déchets par la fenêtre et il
ya une pub récurrentes qui est passé
comme ça je sais pas pourquoi j'ai 100
mais moi j'étais tout gamin on voyait
des gens qui jetaient paraît peut-être
leurs déchets quand il se retourne et à
une tête de cochon et ça m'avait marqué
et j'ai vu aussi
non mais c'est curieux et ça m'avait
vraiment marqué et j'ai vu une
différence entre le début de ces
publicités et aujourd'hui c'est à dire
que je partage parfois entre la france
et le portugal au portugal c'est c'est
monnaie courante les gens jettent leurs
déchets par la fenêtre
en france c'est devenu quand même assez
rare c'est c'est c'est vrai et je pense
que la communication et cette publicité
à lui faire je sais pas si c'est le
meilleur moyen mais abandonné il faut
vraiment toucher les gens et ça c'est
plutôt une publicité intelligente
puisque vous n'avez peut-être une autre
rapport qui en a certaines qui nous
paraissent moins intelligentes
celle ci pour le coût est relativement
essentiel donc entre le carbone score
une information qu'il faut donner au
public je pense que la publicité
télévisuelle peut jouer un rôle
essentiel voilà sur ce point il y avait
une autre question qui était comment
avez vous échangé autour de la
convention et comment êtes vous parvenus
à un consensus
alors l'échangé fait on a vécu en
autarcie cd week-end complet du vendredi
au dimanche soir
au total 6 ter comprenait même le petit
déjeuner le matin on est où je cherchais
à l'hôtel à 8 heures on prenait un petit
déjeuner ont déjeuné sur place ont dîné
sur place dès fois on termine et moi
j'ai fini parfois il était une heure du
matin on nous ramener à noter avec
l'autre but donc c'est vraiment autarcie
je me souviens que le premier vendredi
le premier midi du premier vendredi on
est allée à la cantine du saison et là
je faisais la queue donc pour ce
connaissez pas tous ces dernières mois
et un type charmant que je connais un
peu plus maintenant que ça devait lui
olivier qui dit moi j'ai trouvé la
solution à supprimer les avions donc je
me retourne vers lui je dis ça va être
compliqué quand même pour voyager milan
mais c'est pas grave on va remettre en
place des montgolfières et puis
j'ai dit par contre il va falloir
beaucoup et me dit ouais c'est et on a
commencé à discuter puis à la fin il y
en a c'est vrai que c'est peut-être pas
une bonne idée
voilà comment ça s'est passé ça a
commencé par le déjeuner le petit
déjeuner et puis effectivement on avait
ensuite un groupe de travail qu'on a
intégré dans lequel on avait des
discussions peut-être un peu plus
sérieuse mais malgré tout il ya des
idées farfelues qui sortait comprenait
le temps quand même d'écouter
il y avait des idées plus intelligente
ou trop intelligent ce qu'on prenait le
temps aussi d'écouter mais peut-être
d'abaisser par rapport à la faisabilité
et puis il faut aussi rappeler comme
qu'on avait une équipe d'encadrants
assez extraordinaire pour temporiser un
petit peu toute cette passion tous ces
débats et nous guinéens petit peu vers
vers un cheminement plus logique à
l'écriture de nos propositions
ça commence par les qu'outre l'entente
et l'écoutent
[Musique]